(dramatic music)
- Searching for a ship
or airplane in the ocean
is technically more challenging
than going into space.
You're essentially dealing with
one atmosphere of pressure.
When we go to 6,000 meters,
we're dealing with pressures
that would crush you.
I'm Steve Saint Amour, the
co-founder of Eclipse Group
and a subsea explorer.
We specialize in ultra deep
water search and recovery.
When we go out on an operation,
we find crashed ships
or airplanes in the ocean.
Then upon finding them,
we recover the object.
Over the course of my 32 year career,
I participated in 100 plus high profile
search and recovery
operations, like Air France 447
and a number of military aircraft.
The reason these investigations occur is
to prevent the future loss of life.
Hello Horizon, Steve Saint Amour speaking.
The first step is
receiving the phone call.
When we get the call,
we go out with the ship,
we deploy the side scan
sonar to search the area
where we think the object is.
Upon finding it, we would deploy
the remote operated vehicle
which would go down
and recover the object,
and all the information that's
collected by the vehicle
you're getting the results of
that information in real-time.
And after everything that
we have to go through
to assemble the equipment,
go out, perform a search,
when it finally breaks
the surface of the water,
it's a phenomenal feeling.
It's even better when we get
it up to the deck of the ship.
The proof is there that
you've done your job right.
As a kid, you want to make a difference.
You want to find and, you know, discover new things
and tell people about them,
and that really was, you know, the driving force.
I dreamt of spending the rest of my life
exploring the oceans.
Now I'm living my dream and every day is
a unique challenge and an adventure.